were you the og in this or did you get
this idea from someone else initially
you know
this goes back a long ways i was in
local news before i went to nbc and when
i was in detroit
as a reporter
i was tagging along with the narcotics
team the no crack task force this was 86
87 when crack had taken over detroit and
i was allowed access
to this group
local pd
dea
other federal agencies and we would go
in on these raids right so it'd be the
shotgun the ram the helicon
my cameraman some other cops than me i
mean we went on these raids we lived
this for years and on one of those raids
targeting a drug gang called the
chambers brothers
the cops found these videos
i mean you know old-fashioned 1980s
video vhs vhs
of the gang
capturing their ill-gotten wealth
24-karat gold faucets cars and this one
iconic video of this guy one of the
chambers brothers no not money money
money we rich god damn it i'm gonna buy
three cars tomorrow and a jeep and blah
blah blah blah blah
i got those videos
and we did a five part series called all
in the family
in about
1987
and i held these tapes for 18 months
because this investigation was ongoing
and we broke this thing and the power of
taking people inside
this drug world
caught on and suddenly i was
in detroit but in the middle of a
national story because
you might as well have had hidden
cameras in there and it struck me right
then
the power
of this kind of journalism this kind of
enterprise reporting where you get
inside the story yeah and i never forgot
that
so we had done a lot of hidden camera
investigations with nbc they gave me a
pretty long leash which i always
appreciated
and when this opportunity came up
to work with perverted justice the
online watchdog group which essentially
would find these guys and post them on
their website i thought if we could
combine this with our ability to wire a
house with hidden cameras and
microphones it could be compelling
and so we did it now i didn't know in
the beginning whether or not i had just
wasted tens of thousands of dollars of
the network's money and no one would
show up or
if it would become what it did
and within
the first 45 minutes of our
investigation in bethpage long island we
had two guys
ready to show up at the same time
and before the end of that two and a
half day investigation we had 17 guys
surface
and i thought oh my god what have we got
here
and i thought we'd do it two or three
times and no one would show up and here
we are 18 years later crazy if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]